الى جنوب لبنان حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره ان
مقاتلات اسرائيليه شنت غارات على منطقه
الخردل الواقعه قرب مجرى نهر الليطاني كما
استهدفت طائرات اسرائيليه بصاروخين منزلا
في بلده كفركلا بينما اغارت مسياره
اسرائيليه على بلده يارون في الاثناء اعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه استهدف مجمعا عسكريا
ومواقع وبنا تحتيه تابعه لحزب الله وكان
الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن مقتل جندي واصابه
اخر بجروح بالغه جراء انفجار صاروخ مضاد
للدروع اطلقه حزب الله باتجاه موقع عسكري
في الجليل
الاعلى وقد اظهرت لقطات مصوره لحظه
استهداف القوات الاسرائيليه بالمدفعيه
والطيران منطقه الخردلي جنوبي لبنان
وتزامن القصف المدفعي والغاره التي شنتها
طائرات حربيه اسرائيليه مع مرور عدد من
الفرق الصحفيه في المنطقه وتسبب القصف
الاسرائيلي في اصابه طفيفه لمصور قناه
المنار معنا من الجليل الاعلى مراسله
الجزيره فاطمه خميسي ومن مرجعيون جنوبي
لبنان مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقدي ابدا
معك ايهاب
وجديد هذا الغارات الاسرائيليه التي
استهدفت تحديدا منطقه الخردل في نهر
الايطان
نعم هذه المنطقه شن عليها هذا الصباح ثلاث
غارات استهدفت هذا هذه المنطقه الحيويه
بالنسبه لسكان الجنوب اتبع ذلك بسلسله من
القذائف التي اطلقت من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه التي تتمركز في اصبع الجليل
باتجاه هذه المنطقه سقط على الاقل 15
قذيفه في في محيط منطقه الغرات هذه
المنطقه فيها طريق حيوي يربط قضائي حاصبيا
ومرجعيون وبقيه مناطق الجنوب بمنطقه
النبطيه ويعد ايضا طريق يسلكه المواطنون
باستمرار على هذه الطريق التي تصلهم
بالنبطي التي يتمون منها كل ما يحج
يحتاجون اليه بسبب الظروف والاوضاع التي
تعيشها المنطقه ومنها ايضا تنتقل بعض
الامور اللوجستيه الحيويه من غذاء ودواء
الى هذه المنطقه التي استهدفها الجانب
الاسرائيلي مصور قناه المنار اصيب
ب بشظايا في عينه اليمنى وهي اصابه طفيفه
ايضا نج عدد من المواطنين الذين يسلكون
هذا الطريق باعجوبه اذ ضجت مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بالكثير من الفيديوهات التي
تظهر لحظه القصف على محيط هذا الطريق
الحيوي بالنسبه للسكان لكن هذه ليست
الغارات الوحيده بالنسبه للجانب
الاسرائيلي استهدف صباح هذا اليوم بلده
كفركلا وق قصف منزلا بصاروخين كان هناك
ايضا غاره لمسيره اسرائيليه على بلده
يارون اعلن بعدها حزب الله عن استشهاد احد
مقاتليه في هذه الهجمه بالمسير
الاسرائيليه اليوم الماضي كان شاهد ايضا
سلسله عمليات من جانب حزب الله ست عمليات
شنها على مواقع مختلفه للجيش الاسرائيلي
واستطاع وفقا للبيانات التي اعلنها تكبيد
الجيش الاسرائيلي خسائر بالجنود وال
وايضا بالتحصينات الكثيره التي كان
استهدفها وبث ايضا صورا تظهر لحظات اطلاق
الصواريخ باتجاه هذه المواقع الاسرائيليه
المختلفه